being good with people has historically
been a challenge for me being shy
introverted find it hard to start off
conversations but the thing that
actually helped the most was actually
just be curious about people just find a
way to be curious about somebody because
I think especially if you're introvert
we don't like having very surface level
conversations but we love we actually
love deep conversations and so the way
to do that is to start finding one thing
that you can be really curious about the
person if you can generally be curious
about them then it's so much easier to
have a conversation and you're asking
questions about them and people love
talking about themselves